SHE WAS ONCE CHASED BY A CUE
BALL, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
FOUR HOURS OF MY LIFE GONE
FOREVER.
WATCHED THE OSCARS.
I DID IT FOR YOU.
GRANTED, I DID FALL ASLEEP FOR
ONE HOUR.
OH, DID I DROOL.
STILL THREE HOURS OF MY LIFE
DOWN THE TOILET.
WE CAN FOCUS ON THE POLITICAL
STATEMENTS MADE BUT WE GET THAT
STUFF.
INSTEAD, WHY DO PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO REALLY, REALLY LOVE MOVIES
REALLY HATE THE OSCARS?
I GREW UP WITH THE 1970s
SATURDAY MATINEES WHERE YOU
ARRIVED IN THE MORNING I LEFT
WHEN IT'S DARK.
"PLANET OF THE APES," THE
NEPTUNE FACTOR, WILLARD,
DISASTER ETHICS.
MOVIES WERE ESCAPE FOR A KID IN
SUBURBIA WHEN THERE WASN'T MUCH
ELSE BESIDES CEMENT PLAYGROUNDS
LITTERED WITH PULL TABS AND BEER
CANS.
NOW WE ARE BEING INFORMED, NOT
ENTERTAINED.
THE OSCARS IGNORE THE ESCAPE,
BOWING TO PRESSURES OF
GROUPTHINK.
MOVIES ARE ONES ABOUT
RECAST ART AS A CONDUIT FOR THE
NEW RELIGION OF IDENTITY.
>> NONE OTHER THAN FIRST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE FIRST THREE
QUARTERS OF MOVIES.
WE MAKE THEM TO UPSET MIKE PENCE
WE MAKE THEM TO UPSET MIKE PENC
MIKE PENCE.
>> LIKE EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
AND EVERYONE WATCHING AT HOME,
WE ARE DREAMERS.
>> TO ALL THE DREAMERS OUT
THERE, WE STAND WITH YOU.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
WHY WERE THE OSCARS ON TV TO
BEGIN WITH?
TO SEE THE STAR.
NOW IT'S AN OFF-SITE RETREAT FOR
A TROUBLED INDUSTRY, SOMETHING
YOU MIGHT ACCIDENTALLY WALK INTO
AT A HOTEL RECEPTION HALL.
THE STARS DON'T REALIZE HOW BAD
THEY LOOK WHEN THEY TRY TO TALK
TO AMERICA BY CRASHING A NEARBY
THEATER.
>> YOU ARE LIVE ON THE OSCARS
RIGHT NOW.
YOU SEE THAT?
THERE IS MERYL STREEP.
>> WHO WOULD LIKE A HOT DOG?
DOES ANYONE LIKE A HOT DOG?
DO NOT AIM THE HOTDOGS DOGS AT
THE VEGETARIANS.
FIRE THAT INTO THE CROWD.
THIS IS A LOT OF FUN.
>> EAT AND DANCE AND SCREAM.
>> Greg: WE BROUGHT YOU SOME
GOODIES, YOU PEASANTS.
WE ARE SO MUCH BETTER THAN YOU
ARE.
AS THE OSCARS TRIED TO EXPLAIN
WHY MOVIES MATTER, YOU END UP
HATING EVERYTHING ABOUT MOVIES.
THAT'S NOT FAIR TO THE MOVIES.
IN SHORT, IF YOU HATE THE